hey this is presh talwalker
Ali and Baba need to complete a job
if Ali works alone he will take 16 more
days than if they worked together
similarly Baba would take nine more days
than if they worked together
how many days does the job take when Ali
and Baba work together
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
let's go through the problem step by
step
we need to solve for the number of days
it takes when Ali and Baba work together
so let's suppose that when they both
work together it takes X days
now in a matter of T days they would
complete some percentage of the job we
could write this as the fraction T over
X
when T is equal to X they complete the
job so this is equal to one hundred
percent of the job
now we know that if Ali works alone he
will take 16 more days than if they work
together
so let's suppose that Ali takes a days
and a is equal to 16 plus X
similarly Baba would take nine more days
than if they work together
so if Baba completes the job by himself
in B days we know that Baba B is equal
to X plus nine
so now let's just focus on these
variables
we have X X plus 16 and X Plus 9.
so imagine that Ali and Baba work
together for X days
so we know that the percentage that Ali
does of the job plus the percentage that
Baba does is equal to one hundred
percent of the job
now what's the fraction of the job done
by Ali that will be X over a similarly
Baba's work percentage in X days will be
X over B
the sum of these is equal to one hundred
percent which equals one
but we know that a is equal to X plus 16
and B is equal to X Plus 9. so we could
substitute these in
so we have X over X plus 16 plus X over
X Plus 9 is equal to 1.
so we have a single equation in one
variable let's just focus on solving
this
since X is a positive number X plus 16
and X Plus 9 are not equal to 0.
so we can get rid of the denominators in
this equation by multiplying both sides
of the equation by the factor X plus 16
multiplied by the factor X plus nine
the right hand side simplifies to be X
plus 16 multiplied by X plus nine
to simplify the left-hand side of the
equation we need to distribute
so we'll first do this multiplication
so the denominator X plus 16 will cancel
out with the factor X plus 16 leaving X
multiplied by X Plus 9.
similarly we distribute to the next term
the denominator X plus nine will cancel
out with the factor X plus nine so this
simplifies to be X multiplied by X Plus
16.
we can now simplify this equation
we need to distribute on both sides so
the first Factor will become x squared
plus 9x then we have x squared plus 16x
and this is equal to x squared plus 25x
plus 144.
so we just need to simplify this
equation
now even x squared on the left hand side
which cancels out with the x squared on
the right hand side
9x plus 16x is equal to 25x so this
exactly cancels out with the 25x on the
right hand side and we're left with x
squared is equal to 144.
we need X to be a positive number of
days so we take the positive square root
and that gives us X is equal to 12 days
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time